by redesigning a building that's totally
transparent and the best example of what
I know that everybody can associate with
at least in New York City is the new
Apple building on Fifth Avenue just the
entrance to the apple store is a
remarkable space because everybody sort
of attracted to it what is that it's a
totally transparent and yet it's their
thing now if you can imagine five
stories of that and a half of a city
block and beautiful plants have all
kinds growing inside and restaurants
associated with them all the way around
it and green markets come on what's
wrong with this picture nothing's wrong
with that picture nothing so that's
that's what the future could hold for us
if we decided that this was a good idea
that needs to be at least tried this
year the United States government set
aside three hundred billion dollars for
farm bill three hundred billion dollars
and if you look in that farm bill there
isn't one penny for alternate
agricultural strategies not a cent a lot
of it is farm insurance a lot of his
food aid they have two billion dollars
that's your much for nothing that's just
in case they needed well I raised my
hand but nobody saw it you know cuz I
could have used 1 billion of that how's
that because if I had a billion dollars
or even a half a billion dollars I could
I can well actually might have that so
I'm sort of pre-empting with my next or
your next question to me and that is who
could afford these things if they're
going to be so expensive right but the
fact is that the first one of anything
is expensive the first ten of anything
is expensive but the first maybe the
hundreds one starts to be reasonably
priced and then you know I could take
out my cell phone it's off by the way so
you I can show it to you I mean you
imagine when a cell phone look like 10
years ago right it was clunky and big
and an antenna on it and then everybody
said I need to carry one of these with
me and pretty soon you can't see them
anymore almost there remarkable the
laptop computer involved in the same way
now everybody affords it I wants
everybody because of course there are
tremendous numbers of poor people out
there
everybody should get the same amount of
food though everybody should get the
same amount of water why is that a
privilege rather than a right of being
born into the human race all right it's
not a race by the way because we've lost
that one already it's actually a species
the human is a species a single species
that behaves like a hundred and however
many nations there are in the United
Nations it behaves like that many
different species but it should behave
like a single species in providing the
basics to every one of them because why
because I'll tell you why I think the
reason that I think this will succeed is
from all of the interest expressed from
commercial sources now not domestic you
know people that just come out of the
woodwork and say great idea can I work
with you there are developers now that
are serious about developing and
building vertical farms within what we
would call eco parks are eco-cities
there are 12 of these things being
planned throughout the world it's
remarkable not just in Dubai and not
just in Abu Dhabi and not just in China
although those are places in Incheon
Korea Las Vegas for instance that's a
real interest in this that's a desert
community in case no one has noticed no
well you'd never know that by going
there Phoenix has a big interest in this
I mean any large city that's stuck in
the middle of a desert should have a
huge investment in food now if you're an
Arab country of course you can afford
most Arab not all Adam countries but if
you're a rich our country with lots of
oil you trade oil for food and water and
things like this but they don't even
want to do that anymore what they would
love to do is be self-sufficient so they
can sell everything and make a huge
profit rather than having to spend some
of that on themselves so I think the
logic of this is inescapable and that is
that we must learn to feed the city
people with City grown food